you know what everybody to be quiet for
a second because I want to touch on a
subject I forget what it was but they
were like he's not gonna stop my boys
like he's just not gonna stop he's gonna
do this until he makes everyone's
creativity is their own creativity so if
you don't like it that doesn't mean that
this person over here it is not gonna
like it that's like people love
vulnerability yeah cuz just showing that
you're human and showing that you're
like you make mistakes he's a Canadian
singer and songwriter he's the first
artist to have seven songs from a debut
album chart on the Billboard Hot 100 he
sold an estimated 100 million albums
worldwide making him one of the
best-selling artists of all time he's
Justin Bieber
and here's my take on his top ten rules
for success rule number ten is our
personal favorite and make sure to stick
around although to the end for some
special bonus clips also as justin is
talking if he says something that's
really deep and meaningful to you please
leave it in the comments and put quotes
around it so other people can enjoy as
well
Dan's very you know he's been studying
your dance moves for a while oh yeah
show me something no no you know I'll
embarrass myself Oh show me you don't
apart in the confident video and you
guys like walking in the hall and that
little guy huh
every time I see that I don't control
myself do it yes oh I think so long so
you're doing that 360 your full body no
just okay here so you go and you throw
it this way oh this one goes in the back
this is circle okay so step with the
circle okay so step back step throw it
okay that throw it you guys look like
brothers yeah I think that was pretty
good okay okay yep yep yep throw it
throw well done with a circle just focus
on your body
dad you're joking do it is no step bro
there's a whole circle they're all
missing this Oh what you're missing them
it's a full three I guess it's almost
too so when you're stepping you're
throwing it like that oh two spins
listen I'll just think with the slow one
and then well I'll leave you the fast
upbeat one yeah I'll just go me up real
slow
- and you go real fast hi so though it's
a dumb move anyway
because that's the greatest labor on the
move the move side job you don't know
why you would ever put that a video
that's dance also part of the skate life
for those yeah he stayed shilling why
try let's skate go skating now but yeah
here you ready for this
she rollerblades and he skateboards well
we both strive me we're not great but
it's fun right it's for us that's what I
say this is my dog right here I know for
sure yeah there's times where I'm just
like man this is it's a lot I just want
to go home I'm just like exhausted I'm
tired but I just also remember what I
want in life and what I'm driving and
like striving for and I'm striving for
the most just the best career possible
and to have the most people be able to
listen to my music and be touched by my
music so you got to do the other stuff
that not necessarily what you love but
it it goes along with everything else
what is your biggest regret my biggest
regret is probably um I think everything
I did make me made me who I am today and
I have a story and I just carry there's
a story in the Bible was talks about
this dude who jesus healed and he said
pick up your mat and go and so with that
symbolizes like pick up your past he was
he was a paraplegic and he's like pick
up this mat so you remember where you
were so for me I just remember where I
was and no I'm not where I want to be
necessarily but I'm not where I used to
be and just keep it pushing
your drummer yeah I was drummer really I
am a drummer pause but you know what a
paradiddle isn't it yeah just do a
parlor right now I
okay was it just like a publicity to
your gig sometimes you just tell Joey yo
take five man since I wasn't - really
yeah so you're like the
jack-of-all-trades you mean he played
guitar you see ya got rhythm you play
drums what about doing like a solo album
where you doing everything there across
your body just like I'm so like there's
so many amazing drummers and so many
amazing it's out there yeah I'm not
there yet
like I love playing guitar I love
drumming but you're great but like
there's people all they do is drum
guitar absolutely that's like people
love vulnerability yeah cuz you're
showing that you're human and showing
that you're like you make mistakes and
you are human and you it's just
relatable there's strength and
vulnerability though right yeah you're
strengthened you coming out and
explaining how vulnerable you are yeah
open you are for sure yeah and it takes
a lot as a man to to be able to suck
that pride up and not and because for a
while I just like you don't want to say
sorry you don't want to feel like you're
a weak you know yes a lot of times when
you show like your emotions you feel
weak or portal tell you that that's weak
when you cry or when you do this I'm
like I'm a really emotional guy so I'm
like I'm a crier I'm someone who's like
really open with my emotions yeah and
for a while I felt like I couldn't be
and I felt so guarded that I wasn't
being able to be my true self and like
that rock star lifestyle that's just
like it was cool and it was fire just
wasn't me
by critics alike
there's time you're on stage and you're
like trying to kick like a Jujubee or
something into the crowd well maybe you
were on the side of the stage throwing
in that world are you talking about how
because yeah we just were doing the
crazy stuff like we used to have these
like soundcheck parties that were your
time that's exactly what yeah and before
we do like weird games and he throw
something to me I tried to kick and I
wouldn't stop until I got it I'm like
that type of dude like the other day I
forget what it was but they were like
he's not gonna stop my boys like he's
just not gonna stop he's gonna do this
until he makes I saw it that day so is
it that competitiveness to where like
when everybody's coming down on and you
feel like the media isn't being fair to
you right at some point you got
competitive and just start a fight Mack
right well the thing is is that
throughout it all I always knew my
talent level when I knew what I was
capable of so I was never worried about
coming back you know that might sound
weird and because it was I was such in a
weird place but I I always knew what I
was capable of and at that time I was
just growing up and figuring myself out
and I just happened to be doing it in a
spotlight in front of people so here's a
little different wig we got to you guys
got to make your mistakes and no one got
to see it right for me it's like
everyone gets to see it and obviously
have more accessibility to do crazier
stuff because I'm you know in this
position but um yeah dude I just had to
figure out what like I was what kind of
man I wanted to be and I thought man
he's so lucky mmm nothing happened man
maybe go eats us meet a tourniquet mama
I don't know if it's luck though I did
of course I'm making pop music so it has
to be popular but what is popular
necessarily popular is popular when you
make it popular you know it's not taking
what's already popular and just oh this
is popular I guess this is popular too
there's no stereotype for pop no and I
think when like I just want to break
those barriers we're already breaking
the barriers with having EDM and pop
mixed and playing on top 40 radio you
know so if we continue to just break
those barriers I think there's only
going up from here so you just finished
you album right just a few days ago an
Aussie yep how hard is it to actually
just finished album be like it's done no
more touch-ups no more is it's just cuz
it never feels like it's done
just never feels like it's quite good
enough and um you just have to get to a
point where you're just like fine with
it and so I'm at the point where I'm
just like it's it's good as it's gonna
get for right now and I just want the
world to hear who do you show it to like
the shout to your mom you know you get a
few friends around I show it to all the
people in my circle and all the people
who I respect and care what they think
but at the end of the day I don't really
take what they say and it doesn't really
matter to me because everyone's
creativity is their own creativity so if
you don't like it that doesn't mean that
this person over here it is not gonna
like it yeah it's a personal preference
how do you Justin Bieber but measure
success do you measure like what he's
like winning to you I mean creating
something that you love or doing
something that you love and being
passionate about it and like it's not
like I have to get a number one to
succeed with this song like I succeeded
when I recorded it yeah you know cuz I
was able to do what I loved and put it
on pen and paper and yeah and when
you're making those songs and writing
those songs and recording them do you
ever do you ever think about well I
wonder if the public or like this or 1df
fans a lot all the time all the time
yeah you never know what people are
gonna like and I've I've just got to the
point with just accepting what I feel
and just going with my gut
all these happen because you're
discovered in 2007 on your own YouTube
channel yeah my own YouTube and so if
kids want to set up a YouTube channel do
you have any tips for them I would just
say learn how to tag the video right
because that really like just put like
cute kittens cuz a lot of people like
sir
would you say that something bored cute
kittens yeah just tag yourself as even
if you don't have any cute kittens in a
video just say cute kittens and I'm sure
you'll get some legs okay and then so
this guy sees this sees one of your
videos so yeah and is he still your
manager Scooter still my manager yeah
you know how does it work your
relationship with scooter do you know
just does he do everything you say do
you do if you mean he says have you had
a route did you split up if you get back
together are your songs about him no
he's someone who's probably one of the
most talented businessmen that I've ever
met but he's also someone who really
cares you know it's not all about the
money for him it's about like being
passionate about what he loves and you
got a great family and someone who'll
just yeah he's awesome alright so we're
gonna play here's your paddle I'm sure
you have one because for me to spank
each other yes you can have a question
and we're gonna answer honestly I've
never seen these so okay never have I
ever had phone sex
Wow never have I ever used someone
else's toothbrush without telling them
you never have I ever fooled around in a
bathroom during a party
this is the 21st century's our tame yeah
that's never have I ever gotten kicked
out of a bar I just sent 21 Curt be
honest I just search my way around yeah
just a rumor
Jay I swear all right never have I ever
dated someone and their sibling
never have I ever fooled around with
someone else in the room when someone
else in there with someone else in the
room wave your hands in the air
alright honest fashion or sexual just
saying never have I ever forgotten the
name of the person I was fooling around
with
you two are perfect for each other
that's all that we have I know more it's
a fun game right I feel like I'm getting
to know in my new boyfriend right now in
the spot never have I ever had sex with
two different people with more than two
different people in one day
I mean to different people in a day
Murdaugh here's the thing well what I
want it to be special for my wife I
don't want to play deep that's crazy
let's play defense you just try to stop
him to go and buy you okay see you on
this side all right you're just gonna
try to steal the ball okay ready yeah I
know I'll play D okay go go go shoot it
right oh I should get it the champ is
here the champ is true this isn't music
let's do it
you don't is this a music
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Rodrigo Miz
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down the comments below
and I'll see what I can do I also love
to know what the justin's say that
really had an impact on you what words
of wisdom kind of left a mark on you
leave it down in the comments i'm gonna
join in the discussion finally one thing
give a quick shout out to Kelly Quinton
I hope I pronounced that okay Kelly
bought 10 copies on my book thank you so
much Kelly it really really really means
a lot to me so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
Justin Bieber is the world's hottest pop
star but during his current smash hit
tour of Australia there's only been one
person he's wanted to meet what's up man
how are you good to see you
we're gonna do a handshake this time
yeah there we go
Casey harness the Aussie schoolboy who
stood up to a bully and became a
worldwide internet sensation as our
video is pretty cool
the superstar has flown Casey and his
family to Milburn's rod laver arena as
VIP guests not only are they meeting
Justin and seeing his spectacular show
but he also has a surprise in store that
will be the envy of millions of birds
around the world you don't want to bring
them out here because you know I think
this story began in a schoolyard in
western Sydney back in March a bully and
his mates corner Casey and video their
victim as he cops punch after punch
until suddenly he snaps I was just just
looking at him I wasn't really thinking
I was just like yeah he finally it's
over I want to ask you like what what
was it like like just like was your
adrenaline just rushing when it all
happened yeah that's it yeah this just
happened
so he was just hitting you and then you
just snapped yeah has he bullied you
before that yeah about two weeks prior
before that and that's pretty much and
so then you just were Talia yeah
just give him a Powerball the video was
posted online and went viral touching
the hearts of everyone who saw it the
moment that a victim of bullying finally
said enough is enough
well I saw this story and just kind of
touched my heart
punching him and then suddenly a big hit
it too much and they weren't fighting he
defended himself
that was my everybody on this planet who
has seen your video is in your corner
Casey you're a man
and I salute you why do you think that
that so many people have reacted the way
that they have to what you did because
people get bullied all the time
everybody wanted to know more about the
boy in the video he told his story to a
CA how long has this been going on in
primary school you two all the way up to
year six and one day high school
one person started it I had about eight
friends i ate french ditched me that
first year and then the teasing started
from there when you say teasing what do
you mean call me my fatty and all of
that and slap me across the back of
their head like tripping me throwing
water bombs at me how often would with
this stuff go on practically every day
would you recommend it to other people
who are being bullied to do what you did
not really what should they do I try
Walker's ways as much as you can what if
a fight does break out it happens
Casey told a tragic tale of being
bullied all his life our story was seen
by millions of people one of them was
Justin Bieber Justin what did you think
when you saw the video for the first
time I thought when I first saw I saw it
on TMZ and I was like like this is crazy
I can't believe this I think this is
amazing is it shows everybody else like
that you have to stand up for for
yourself and you know you can't just
take it you know as you have the first
thing you do is you know either go tell
someone or you know you can't always you
know hit back but you sometimes you have
to and so I think that was important for
you especially in that situation so I'm
proud of you and so many other people
but no one is prouder than KC's dad :
Justin Bieber was keen to meet him - how
are you good so how did you feel when
you like when you saw you know your son
I was very proud of you if I'm very
proud yeah it was - been like heart you
know heart aching to see like you know
put people balls yeah yeah well you see
keeps getting pushed around like that in
high school yeah it should never have
happened you know where any of you oh is
any people like standing up for you
anything no except for the girl that
came in after that's pretty much it yeah
the rest of them are just on the other
side filming it yeah that's right I mean
more people need to stand up for
belonging like because it happens so
much and like it's one thing to get
bullied and stand up for yourself but
more people have to like stand in and
actually you know do something because
yeah and stuff but yeah because people
just get bullied enabled us to you know
you can't be a feisty and roll your life
and you there's almost got to step in
and say sorry can I stop everyone has to
starting right now Justin Bieber is one
of the most popular people on the planet
everywhere he goes he's surrounded by
screaming fans but just a few years ago
it was a very different story
did you get bullied at school Justin um
I did yeah it was actually something
happened a lot from me you know I was
always I always played sports and stuff
and a lot of the times you know I I
would be really good at something and so
everyone would you know wouldn't like me
because I was good at it and they would
you know make fun of me and and call me
a show-off and stuff but you know I was
just I liked playing sports and I was
good at it like I see Justin also found
it hard to make friends you know in like
sixth grade I just remember you know I
was I didn't have like a lot of friends
I had like you know maybe one or two
friends I have one from a friend one
friend I have two friends I have one
more but yeah I have two friends Ryan
and Chaz and they've been you know my
friends ever since I can remember so I'm
glad you know you always have to keep
your core you know ran that's true of
stuff but you got a lot of fans around
the world as a victim of bullies
Justin felt inspired by Casey story he
was determined to track him down he
really wanted to make this happen so he
got in contact with women's day the
phone rang it was Justin Bieber on the
other end of the line we went well of
course we're going to make this happen
so we got in contact with you guys and
the rest is history
as it turned out one of Justin's crew
had a contact at Woman's Day the star
himself past editor Fiona Connelly to
help find Casey this is highly unusual
you just don't see celebrities giving
this kind of treatment to a regular kind
of fan any day he's gone to
extraordinary lengths but Justin didn't
want to just meet Casey he wanted his
help in spreading the anti-bullying
message so I wanted to ask you if you
wanted to come on stage tonight cuz I do
this kind of you know anti-bullying you
know we do a lot of different stuff we
do no texting and driving during the
show so I wanted you to come up and kind
of just say hi to everybody and just
come onstage you want to do that yeah
I'll do that
cool all right so it'll be around 9:30
you think you can handle that
we'll see you on stage yeah I've had it
yeah
Justin make sure Casey is sister Tiana
and dad Colin had front-row seats and
then during a brief costume change the
16 year old school boy was taken
backstage for some last-minute tips from
the teen sensation I want to ask if
anybody in here has been bullied before
okay how many people in here have seen
people get bullying all right well you
know those um there was a story online a
kid was getting bullied right and at the
end of the video he stood up for what
you know for himself because he was you
know he's getting punched and you know I
want to bring him out here because you
know I think he can
what's up
I think this date is very inspirational
because everybody give it up for this
day I would say I'll tell you to
bodyslam del but you know anyways but I
just wanted to say that you know he's
very inspirational he shows other people
to stand up for you know what they
believe in and and and what else what
else you go say you gotta say it really
loud to kids once lonely once bully now
adored by thirteen thousand screaming
fans
like being up there on the stage with
Justin Bieber
you believe your brother was up there
with Justin Bieber no I couldn't at
first I'm just like nah this isn't
happening
Haizi massive just felt so special up on
that stage he's only ever been up on
stage once then that was at the school
hall playing bass guitar so to have
thousands of screaming teenage girls
suddenly screaming for him I think I
think that would have been such a
special experience for him the owner
Connolly from Woman's Day says what
happened on that stage in Melbourne will
have an impact around the world it sends
a very important message on bullying I
mean here's Justin Bieber superstar of
the teen world and he's saying no it's
not a riot it was great you know good
really good thing and it was good that
Justin was prepared to put out a message
against bullying and I thought that was
fantastic
long after Justin had left the building
fans were still caught up in Bieber
fever
Casey the boy they're just seen on stage
suddenly became the center of attention
it was a moment be lapped up and with
screams ringing in their ears even
members of the band wanted their photo
taken with Justin Bieber's
the kid who once suffered at the hands
of bullies now one of the boys this is
such an amazing story it's just such a
beautiful feel-good inspiring story and
it really sheds a great light on Justin
and Casey's enjoyed every minute
how do you feel when all these people
come up and say you're all these girls
he won't fight with you
Giada this place is changed or since the
last time we spoke to heat
self-confidence has picked up quite a
bit change a lot straighter my
nice to meet you nice to meet you too
nice to meet you dad
what surprised you the most of actually
being in person and working with Justin
Bieber you know from all the stuff you
know all the stereotypes everything you
hear on the media whatever maybe what's
surprising no matter what anybody says
he's the most talented gifted kid I've
ever seen like at everything he gets
skateboard he can like beat everyone and
pool he got like when I got the Iowa
actually showed him the Iowa Hawk and he
got right on I was doing like one footed
tricks and like he's just so talented
and competitive and wants to be good at
everything he's also really polite sweet
sweet person as well like bringing my
friends in the studio and just other you
know artists that I've been bringing out
of the project hope collaborate on the
record he's just you know he's on fire
right now and I think he's really that
experience that we had over Justin
Bieber is there a story that you think
will stand out that you'll be telling in
the future to like your grandchildren
and whatnot like something that went
down in studio that was hilarious or so
weird or funky you know what that wasn't
real yeah I'm decent at skateboarding
for not being a skateboard he almost
beat me in a game of skate almost being
the keyword it's debatable but he um you
know like young horse when you play
basketball there's skate so you land a
trick or you can do a tricky land where
the other person is land it you get a
letter sk8 EE right so we were playing
skate and he almost beat me and I was
really surprised that Justin Bieber
almost beat me in a game of skate I'm
saying he's good at everything
he freestyles like sometimes we'll just
make a beat and then like you'll get in
the booth and just start free sighing
hilarious like comedian and we'll just
be sitting there in stitches like ten
minutes not getting any work done just
like telling jokes I love that I love
that guy that made me melt
damn damn JB whatever you yeah
got a new necklace diamonds too big face
Raleigh's no I ain't lyin make your mama
so proud that she crying get you Sam
crazy guess that makes two but I never
knew that dreams really came true
started playing drums when I was only 2
now we could get in Japan kung fu so I'm
heading for the gold I'm sweating us
we're Otis Redding we'll be oh so ready
I already got a heady other game I'm
with Kenny and we said he get him any
yummy money riding into all black Benz
with the all-black rims and we looking
at some pencil all black lenses wait
wait I think Jesus at the awards I'm
never going to he'll call me Zack Morris
I'm saving you by the Bell my girl says
I'm perfect he just loves an imperfect
person perfectly personally I think she
is perfectly perfect get it done
abundantly she wants to get up under me
that's where that I got honey DS cuz
baby I my money tree so be my little
honey be my little baby bunny I got
honey's all up on me baby I just get it
honey possibly you're probably thinking
this type of swagger possible and
logically we'll probably but you just
hit me Lamberty try to feel me
spiritually get out you might literally
there's a bigger me inside this little
me screaming out I should make history I
am like a mystery hater by jealousy cuz
they ended me running up on my enemy see
if they remember me as soon as they
remember me I wipe away their memory
can't you see the private jets flying
over you ain't even notice what my focus
on my photos might be bogus how they
shouldn't be a photo shoot it's funny
how you wanna take my picture and it's
like your first time playing with the
camera claiming that it's not mine just
calm down
you don't gotta hurry you don't be
nervous yo you don't gotta worry and my
fans alike my glasses yeah without I
might be blurry
let me start up with the old-school flow
snapback backpack Ratatat go swagger out
the knapsack who knew I could rap dad
tell me what a cat's gotta tell you what
a smash it number one hits I got number
one flicks in the number one kicks in
the number one chicks fast like Gordon
and my gyms like Jordan and materials
like Hortons in my jets all aboard and
and my wheels are like a fortune and it
feels like extortion is it for the fame
or the fortune like this Mike just so
what camera cyclists people in their
basements
didn't even write this people say I'm
white so I couldn't do it like this
checks like Nike let me give you a
goodnight kiss
well I'm a little bit sick of it listen
to the bickering like picking on a
little kid like taking all this licorice
I hate it when they litter and I'd hate
to be illiterate I literally am doing
these riddling cheese like Gouda and was
so like Buddha and my goal right through
you and I so much cooler and I don't
need Loula to know that I'm the ruler
and I'm so much cooler you should call
me Ferris Bueller ten you were here it
was five years ago I'm good at math and
you you had a drum off for the quest I
did yeah that was fun yeah and it was
yeah well yeah thank you
it destroyed me but no it's okay it
doesn't matter this is five years ago
yeah but it's been five years
no you go first
single at the end of the show
you knock them out ha ha
I got a chance to anyway maybe we can
make it two maybe together we can get
somewhere any places
starting from me - I got nothing to lose
maybe we'll make something be myself I
got nothing to lose my old man's got a
problem there's not a lot of us away a
day as I said buddy some old for work in
Buddy soon-young so look like this my
mama went off and left him she wanted
mother life then he could give it said
somebody's gotta take care of him you
know I quit school that's what I did so
remember when we were driving driving in
your car speak so fast I felt like I was
drunk city lights lay out far and down
to the wreck right around my shoulder
and I I had a feeling that I belong a
feeling I could be someone